what are the BBC guidelines on
impartiality and do they apply to Gary
lineker
[Music]
Gary lineker took to Twitter to hit out
at the government's illegal migration
bill which bans migrants who arrive on
small boats from settling in Britain he
tweeted this is just an immeasurably
cruel policy directed at the most
vulnerable people in language that is
not dissimilar to that used by Germany
in the 1930s
[Music]
the BBC says it's committed to what it
calls due impartiality in the guidelines
state that impartiality must be adequate
and appropriate to the output they say
taking account of the subject and nature
of the content the likely audience
expectation and any signposting that may
influence that expectation they say that
the BBC output must always scrutinize
arguments question consensus and hold
power to account with both consistency
and during partiality
foreign
the BBC guidelines do note that social
media is now part of everyday life and
they do see a difference between what
they call BBC spaces that are run by the
BBC for BBC purposes and then what they
also cause personal spaces so there'd be
a distinction between an official
Twitter account say for BBC News versus
the private account of somebody who
particularly like Gary lineker doesn't
work in news or journalism however the
BBC guidance also states that similar to
official platforms all activity whether
it's in a professional or personal
capacity should be informed by their
editorial guidelines
of course Gary lineker is not a
permanent member of Staff here at the
BBC he's a freelance presenter and he
also works in sport not news or politics
so the rules are a little looser on him
than they would be on someone like Hugh
Edwards but guidelines at the BBC also
say that figures who are clearly
identified with the corporation are also
expected to behave appropriately and in
ways they say that are consistent with
the BBC's editorial values and policies
and that here seems to be the main issue